louis sonde avec un bâton il tente de
connaître l'épaisseur du nid de
sargasses qui s'est étalée sur la plage
du fort ça au françois
si j'allais rejouer il ya des pêcheurs
beaucoup de passionnés de yole avaient
fait le déplacement pour assister au
grand prix de la fédération mais hélas à
cause des sargasses la régate a été
annulé bon
la presqu'île où se trouve au nombre de
yole franciscaine
la situation est similaire pour ses
anciens violeur qui sont pour certains
des marins pêcheurs
ce n'est qu'un début il ça risque
d'empirer face à cette invasion de
sargasses la solution la plus sûre il
est donc l'annulation de la régate qui
vraiment il y à beaucoup de sagesse qui
agit sur toute la côte atlantique
on va essayer de se retourner vers la
côte caraïbe on essaiera le voir dans
quelles villes les choses de se dérouler
mais là nous sommes durement tributaire
de la nature et puis également
tributaire justement de la sécurité
puisque nos canaux suiveurs qui nous
suivent
il faut qu'ils puissent naviguer en
toute sécurité et léo leur bien sûr sans
abîmer leur matériel parfois le malheur
des uns fait le bonheur des autres
cette famille par exemple des qpr des
sargasses pour son jardin
quel bon pour les plaintes et équipier
voir que mes dessins
[Musique]
des citrons tout ça dimanche prochain
une course de bébés hall est programmé
toujours au françois
une réunion entre la municipalité la
fédération se tiendra lundi afin de
déterminer si la régate pourra avoir
lieu